what got you into acting what got me
into acting well I guess it was without
getting into how old I have but it was
an 80 was an 86 sorry
it was in 90 probably about 94 I was
working for Walt Disney World and
Orlando great job I was I was waiting
tables and it was one of those jobs at
least in Florida it's even a little bit
different in California I really loved
it I loved working with people I love
doing what I do but I didn't feel like I
was really getting like my purpose in
life wasn't really I felt like I there
was something else I should be doing but
I liked the job and I worked a schedule
where I worked for days had three days
off and there was this acting class kind
of you know to work on your confidence
and I never had much confidence so I
decided to take it and it was weird
because um looking back on it like
everything was a little bit fuzzy in my
life trying to figure it out and when I
took this acting class everything became
clear it was almost like a weird cosmic
thing and and I decided I had to do it
to make a long story short after a
number of classes it's it's one of those
things every class I took I just felt
like there was like I felt like I had a
blonde something I could up longing to
to a career I guess this is what I'm
trying to say so that's what got me in
acting and how long were you at Disney
World I worked there for almost seven
years right as I got out of college and
it was amazing
amazing company to work for and probably
wasn't for acting but I probably would
still be there so I really I really
loved working for me do you remember the
day that you packed up your car
yes I do I had to make a really
interesting story on that I had met this
girl in my acting class and she was
planning on moving out here I really
wasn't in a relationship and to make a
long story short we we had known each
other almost five months and we decided
just to move out here she didn't know
anybody I didn't know anybody and I
guess you know we were both growing and
got engaged really really quick we just
moved out here and so I moved out here
with her and it was a it was a sighting
feeling just because of not only moving
out here really starting my career
something that I really wanted to do but
I really started I was thought I was
starting my personal life as well but
you know that didn't work out with her
and which is fine I mean in every every
life has this lesson and but as far as
remembering the day that I moved out
here I just remember being exciting
feeling because I felt like I was
starting something flash forward a
couple years into being in Los Angeles
how's that enthusiasm still there oh
gosh I would love to be able to tell you
Karen that it was uh it's always been
bright but you know it could have been a
compliment of like things to work out
with her but I la took a lot to grow on
me or you know I try to be a positive
person but there's a lot of I felt like
a lot of negative energy a lot of people
are probably with good reason they're
just out for themselves trying to make a
career for themselves and I really felt
like I didn't really didn't belong here
and I ended up I have a sister listen in
San Diego and after about two or three
years I'd end up living down there for a
year just basically uh you know surfing
during the day because that's what I
love to do and in Florida and just
working at night and I was happy I
really felt a sense of relief doing that
for about four months but then I
realized I had to make a decision
and this is I guess how I operate I
needed to move back to Florida because
Disney would always still be there or be
an actor and at the end of the day I
guess I just couldn't let act and go
it's something that just it was like um
it was like a high like when I was when
I was acting and creating that um just
feeling it was amazing and I I had to I
couldn't let it go so I'm going back to
you LA
you